hey what up guys it's the crew that
wrote danger boys he got me Joe Casey
Steve and next Friday we're gonna be
screening danger boys at UC Irvine
January 17th at 5:45 p.m. but if you're
Asian go there at 5:00 gonna be late and
it's open to the public so make sure you
get your tickets baby and secret secrets
guess what I'm gonna be bringing more
people from JK also will you be playing
a live instrument there that I will and
this is our first screening in the LA OC
area so shout outs to you CIS pi Alpha
Phi for bringing us out there so if you
guys are in this area make sure you go
there because I don't know when the next
time gonna be danger boys is a
mockumentary about that follows the
least threatening gang in the San
Gabriel Valley and you go check it out
so we made danger boys because we wanted
to make something that would put the 66
on the map and as you know barb Jonah
from the 66 and a lot of their original
skits were were inspired by this area
and so we wanted to do a show that
captured the spirit of the area while
making fun of it yes yes yes
especially the time period that we grew
up in which no one really knows now and
like the history kind of got you erased
you want to bring that back but in a
funny way yep so if you want to go to
the screening no matter where you are in
the whole entire world if you go down to
the link below you can buy that ticket
and show up in the flesh you can meet us
you can watch the show you can watch our
first ever screaming and laugh with us
and hang out with us after the screening
there's gonna be a Q&A where me Joe
Casey Steve are gonna be there so you
have to talk to us meet us hang out with
us hugs do all kinds of cool stuff so
see you guys there and and secrets
secrets again more JK people and friends
of JK people will be showing up and crew
listen these screenings they're not
gonna happen for long okay and danger
boys isn't gonna be on the internet for
a long time so you might as well come to
this or if you can't come to this
because you're out of state drive from
out of state to this so that you can
check it out and for those of you guys
that are out of state and would like to
set up your own danger boy screening go
to
book jkf at gmail.com and we can arrange
and make that happen
see you there mofo happy birthday